oh I'm sorry I'm just getting this
breaking news
now back to a tub watch 2016 update
updates now the total count is now 17
dead from cuteness let's check in with
the puppy's progress and see how he's
doing with that bath live from the scene
not sure what breed that is it looks
like something to Muppet baby cops up
when he chokes on cotton candy but it is
adorable
comedians this puppy is permed and
dangerous I would like you to give me an
eyewitness description of the perp so
that people can be on the lookout look
oh it looks like a deer has pooped on a
cloud yes yeah boy yeah these like these
are little poops lips tiny deer poo poos
there's the door well aren't you guys
feeling better already about the world